là où ça bouge nous sommes à alençon
pour retrouver dans quelques instants
ici même dans ce fauteuil
philippe caubère un des grands auteurs
acteurs français il est là ce soir à
alençon et il sera mardi à flers mais
pour l'instant on va à l'université pour
assister à l'enregistrement d'une
musique de film un court métrage avec
les collégiens du collège pasteur
de quoi vous allez tout savoir
là où ça bouge nous sommes à
l'université de caen pour un projet un
petit peu exceptionnel et particuliers
dont didier ory le responsable du choeur
et orchestre universitaire régional va
nous parler
oui un cours pour un cours un cours pour
un courrier un court métrage fait par
thomas leroux thomas a fait un ancien
étudiant en arts du spectacle de
l'université est le premier de
l'université de caen être rentrer à la
famille sécu aussi chanté dans le cadre
universitaire il ya quelques temps donc
il a fait un court métrage voilà et là
il m'a contacté pour nous mettre en
contact avec un coeur d'enfant
et puis à en découvrant le film didier
se dit mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on est un
peu plus loin et pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne serait pas participer les coeurs et
les cordes ensemble avec le piano pour
la musique du fis ce que vous allez
chanter là tout à l'heure c'est ce qu'on
appelle en langage cinéma c'est le
climax et hier c'est le point d'émotion
maximale du film c'est à dire que le
spectateur à ce moment là moi ma petite
idée ce serait qu'il verse sa petite
larme
alors c'est de réunir autant de monde
pour juste 15 minutes
mais oui mais c'est ça mais une minute
c'est par son câble expliquer mais si
c'est raisonnable c'est aussi un projet
pédagogique c'est l'occasion donc de
découvrir comment on travaille des
professionnels comment on va caler cette
séquence musicale sur le film et parmi
ces professionnels
il y a bien sûr les compositeurs de
cette musique mathieu l'anglais et
anthony egéa nous suivrons dans l eau c
b le parcours de ce film qui transporte
le rêve d'une petite fille et qui dit
jeu sélectionné pour un festival à tokyo
comme je vous le disais la scène
nationale 61 propose trois événements il
ya tout d'abord philippe caubère ce soir
alençon avec la danse du diable et vous
serez aussi à flers mardi et puis vous
avez aussi le bac 68 que vous allez
proposer vous êtes acteur je le disais
est vraiment hauteur de votre propre vie
et de vo comédie c'est votre matériaux
c'est un petit peu votre vie oui plus
exactement ma jeunesse je n'ai pas
encore vraiment raconter ma vie j'ai
raconté ma vie jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans
donc c'est ma jeunesse et la danse du
diable est une évocation de vraiment de
mon enfance marseillaise et de mon
adolescence
mais de gaulle à raison d'être et evo
toute la journée vous êtes des veaux il
leur dit vous êtes des beaux mais mme
othman de savaria a pu contre la
connerie mais vous c'est différent parce
que vous êtes espagnol
c'est pas du tout du stand-up je
m'adresse pas au public en tant que
philippe caubère il m'arrivait un
shopping mais c'est en tant que claudine
ou en tant que ferdinand fort entendre
qu'ils sont les claudine c'est le
personnage de ma mère qui m'a inspiré ma
mère qui est le personnage un peu
principale de la centrale de la perte
bien sûr voilà et faire dénoncer mon
double c'est moi 14 ou 15 ans et jusqu'à
18 ans 20 ans n'ont offert d'acheter un
cabriolet ces choses là
s'il fait rien je tenterais bien rigoler
dans ton coin là bas on ne ris pas tu as
perdu n'en parlait souvent d'énergie
vous les comparez même à une sorte
d'énergie sexuelles sur celle des
visites
samsam emporte c'est comme un orgasme
qui dure trois heures il est plus
difficile
vous avez toujours 7,7 fois de la scène
comme comme exutoire où comme comme
énergie voyons si vous voulez j'ai pas
le choix
alors j'ai parlé l'énergie sexuelle bien
sûr ce que je pense que l'énergie
sexuelle est à l'origine de tout nous
comment dirais-je une création avec eux
cette énergie on fait des enfants
on va vers les autres les hommes les
femmes ont on aime monde où en est
d'ailleurs ce qui est la frontière est
ténue
on est on fait des oeuvres artistiques
et on énonce existent pour la cn
en effet après il ya une autre énergie
sportive aussi parce qu'il faut assurer
vous aimez faire rire philippe copin oui
ah oui ben oui c'est j'aime faire rire
j'aime faire pleurer à la fin de la
danse du diable il ya des gens qui
pleurent
j'aime faire éprouver des sensations des
émotions j'essaye de faire un théâtre on
s'ennuie pas déjà première chose qu'on
s'ennuie pas vraiment ensuite si on peut
rire c'est formidable si on peut pleurer
c'est encore mieux
merci infiniment philippe roberge vous
êtes invités par la scène nationale 61
avec deux représentations ce soir à lens
on est mardi à flers pour la danse du
diable et ensuite pour le bac 68 ce sera
demain soir
ici même à lens on remercie infiniment
d'avoir maintenant pour nous pour la
bouche merci merci